I suppose that he is slick and that he
is a lizard person but but everything
every single what is that mean well
lizards are are slippery but every
single thing that he said was a lie
everything he said I mean this place
California and come on bill this place
did you see the homeless encampment
right outside this studio right outside
the studio I actually brought some fenel
I talk about I got I talk about
California's problems a lot which is
probably why go Governor Nome has not
been on the show in 6 years yeah so I
don't pull my punches on that I
understand that oh no I'm not saying you
pull your punches but but the fact is
every number that Hannity pulled out
there whether it's homelessness whether
it's the amount of people that left
California to move to Florida whether
it's what's going on with all the woke
stuff that I know you do care about and
all the rest of it Florida is
flourishing